la tunisie en pleine crise sanitaire
économique mais surtout politique avec
un remaniement ministériel
loin de calmer les tensions et de faire
l'unanimité dans la classe politique
tunisienne
un remaniement qui n'a fait que raviver
les tensions entre le premier ministre
ni chichis et le président de la
république le chef de l'état continue de
s'opposer à la nomination de certains
candidats
selon lui la constitution n'auraient pas
été respectées je suis prêt au dialogue
mais je ne suis pas prêt à parler avec
ceux qui ont volé le peuple tunisien je
ne reculerai pas devant mes principes
j'ai juré devant dieu en mettant ma main
sur le coran de respecter la
constitution
ce remaniement ministériel doit être
accompagnée d'une délibération en
conseil des ministres comme le stipule
la constitution une procédure qui n'a
pas été respectée selon le président de
la république qui refuse de recevoir ces
nouveaux ministres rendant des
portefeuilles clefs comme l'intérieur la
santé ou encore l'emploi toujours vacant
une impasse politique alors que le
gouvernement doit faire face à une vague
de manifestations de tout un peuple
exaspérés par la répression policière
les inégalités ou encore la corruption